you have 10 million eu citizens living
under authoritarian rule
we can never tolerate a sick democracies
in european union
we have not problems only in hungary but
also in poland
also in malta the insurrection in
washington has focused attention on the
apparent fragility of democracy in the
u.s
but how strong is democracy in europe my
guest this week from germany is gunther
crick baum
an mp from angela merkel's cbu party and
chair of the eu affairs committee in the
federal parliament
why the big gap between the eu's
rhetoric about rights and rule of law
and the dismal reality in parts of the
[Music]
union
[Music]
going to creek bomb welcome to conflict
zone
good morning when berlin took over the
rotating eu presidency it set itself the
task
of protecting fundamental values and
rights in the european union
and i want to look first at whether it
met that objective in any way at all
according to human rights groups you
have now
almost 10 million eu citizens living
under
authoritarian rule in hungary aren't you
ashamed of that
well i'm not totally satisfied with uh
the results uh to be very honest
but anyway uh we are able to achieve the
first
step to connect uh financial aid
from the budget of the european union to
the respect of rule of law
yeah but that wasn't quite my wasn't my
question about
hungary you have 10 million eu citizens
living under authoritarian rule
and you have the commission's vice
president eu commissions vice president
vera gerava
went so far as to call hungary a sick
democracy
how many sick democracies can you
tolerate in the european union these
days
we can never tolerate sick democracies
in european union but you're hungry
but you do no no one second please let
me achieve
my sentence because we have not problems
only in hungary but also in poland
also in malta when a journalist was
killed
and we had to observe that authorities
did not really
persuade the case so i think it is
necessary
to make more pressure on these states
and
with a budget we have really a tool now
in our hand
and so i'm satisfied that we did the
first
step but i think also it's not and will
be not enough
in the future but it should be normal to
respect rule of law in the european
union
yes well they've gone a long way from
what you regard as normal then
this tool that you're talking about is a
mechanism which germany proposed
that looks as though the eu would make
payments to member countries conditional
on their respect for the rule of law um
the problem for several countries was
that it was just too soft in fact it was
all hype wasn't it
when you looked at the fine print of the
proposal it turned out this mechanism
could only be used if the rule of law
if the violations of rule of law
affected or
seriously risked affecting the sound
financial
management of the eu so in other words
it was all about money
and that wasn't enough for a lot of
countries was it i
i think money is a very good tool to
make pressure on states because they
need the money
and uh so finally it was necessary to
find a compromise
because i think you followed the debate
how difficult it was
to get a solution concerning the mutual
financial framework
and also the recovery fund which allows
now to rebuild the
economy of the concerned states due to
the con
corona crisis but anyway now we
have not only the mechanism
the combination with the financial aid
of the budget but
also article 7 procedure that means
finally we have the
the high court of the european union and
it's up to them
now to decide if there are violations of
rule of law or not
but anyway i think it is worthwhile to
have now this combination
uh with a with a budget but mr creeper
i'm your article seven
processes against poland and hungary
have gone absolutely nowhere
and then it looks as though uh none of
this is going to result in any
sustained action whatsoever and this
latest mechanism also
ended in failure because both hungary
and poland announced
that if you went ahead with it and and
they would veto the latest
stimulus package straight unashamed
blackmail wasn't it
and you gave into it no i i don't share
this opinion because um hungary did
always
respect the decisions of the high card
and this is also for me personally the
red
line the red line means to respect the
decisions
of the high court so that's decisive and
uh hungary did in the past and i think
they will also do in the future
there we have more problems with poland
and uh so
my uh i ask uh opponent also to respect
these
decisions and now we have
once again this mechanism to respect
rule of law
otherwise we can block the money and
this is
one consequence one impact which will be
filled by the concerned states
i have to take issue with you when you
say that uh you know this mechanism
survived intact what what you did was
in fact climb down berlin brokered a
deal that will have the effect of
delaying for months
even years the use of this procedure and
then only after the european court of
justice has ruled on it
and hungary and poland have had the
chance to challenge it
who knows how long that's going to take
so this has been kicked
indefinitely into the future in other
words nothing will happen will it
uh i don't think so because the decision
which will be taken by the european
court will also have an
impact from the very beginning and not
only for the future it means
when the decision will be taken by the
european court so
this was a a very important point for
the netherlands
and so once again i'm
um i'm really glad that we have
now this combination uh between
the budget and a respect of rule of law
which was not
the case in the past let's see how well
it works it said a precedent
that you will climb down you will climb
down every time there is a challenge
and every time states say we're going to
blackmail you and hold up your stimulus
package or your budget
i think it was now right to do
one step in the right direction uh but
it's um
it's it's a trip uh normally i think
um it should be very clear a state which
joins
european union should respect the rule
of law
so that's also the reason why the
article 7 procedure
is only regulated with a
few sentences in the treaty take also
brexit um a brexit is on the basis it
was done on the basis of article 15.
but look on article 15 article 15 there
are only a few sentences
why because we thought it will never
happen that one state will leave
european union that's the explanation
why these rules are very poor
if you want in the treaty so it was our
duty it was our
challenge now to develop mechanisms
for things which are normally a
self-understanding
and when i say normally
self-understanding i get a problem
in arguing to the to the candidate
states
so these states who want to join
european union
because i tell them well if you want to
join european union
you have to respect democracy you have
to respect rule of law
and et cetera et cetera so but also
they have to respect the rule of law one
eu official said after this
latest you call it compromise i call it
climb down
said the rule of law mechanism is like
the stability pact for the east
it will never be enforced and will only
create political
resentment on all sides that's the view
of some people
within the eu and if this mechanism does
re-emerge
that's their opinion and they have the
right of this opinion
for this opinion but it's based on what
happened isn't it
the opinions based on what happened
they're just looking at what happened
i'm really astonished that they judge
about a mechanism
which now starts to work we have now to
observe how it works
uh but uh i i think that's really funny
uh
to uh to condemn a mechanism which was
born now and let's observe now uh how it
works
and nobody can really tell that it will
not work and i don't think so it will
work
let's see in the future and if it will
not be the case
then i'm really sure there will be the
pressure
uh to uh to achieve it in the right
sense
so i'm satisfied once again that we got
this mechanism
that we did this step and now let's
observe how it works
well i would say then that you're easily
satisfied mr creek bam because
human rights organizations for instance
human rights watch are far from
satisfied they said last month the last
weeks have shown that leaders who
violate human rights
have no shame in bullying and
blackmailing the whole european union
to shield themselves from any
consequences for their actions
you set a dangerous precedent here when
you allow this to take place
i don't want to interrupt you but we
have to be very carefully we are
speaking about
member states of the european union and
everybody knows how important it is to
respect
rule of law and so but we are not
talking about a state
uh from another corner in in the world
with a doubtful regime with a doubtful
governance and so on
so no but you are talking you are
talking about european union states that
disrespect the ruling
we have to make a difference we are not
speaking about
a a state of central africa etc
where human rights are violated every
day
let me just make a point here let me
just let me just make a point here
about european union that's not all
perfect
because it's not all perfect then we
have um
also to react the reaction was done and
i think it was part of a very
successful german presidency because it
was not only the mechanism of rule of
law
it was also to come to a result
in the negotiations uh about the
finances of future violence
mr creek well let me let me just
raise an issue here you say you're not
talking about african states you're
talking about members of the
european union you're talking about in
the case of hungary at least
a leader who effectively gave himself
absolute power
under cover of the pandemic who's been
politicizing
the courts who's decimated independent
media who's been chipping away at
academic freedom these are not things
they signed up to do
when they joined the european union so
unless there are mechanisms and
so far no mechanisms have persuaded the
leadership in hungary to change
their course of policy things aren't
going to change
and to go back to my original question
at the top of the interview
what have you managed to do to ensure
rights for those 10 million hungarians
who live according to the human rights
organizations under authoritarian rule
in the middle of the european union you
seem to find that acceptable
they don't well once again
i think it is worthwhile to make a
difference
also in hungary we have a government
first which is
elected by the democratic procedure
but i always criticized
when we have not fair conditions for the
medias
that's the point it is not the case that
nobody can
tell is free opinion uh so
that's my point where i say it's
necessary
to make a difference and once again
we i want to have fair conditions for
the medias
i want uh that each media
can present itself on an economic basis
which is
sure and which will not be violated by
state
so but i think it is not uh only black
and only
white so we have also differences
and uh that's i think that the point
when um we are the opinion when the
european commission
is the opinion that the treaties are uh
violated
then it's the duty of the uh commission
uh to ask for a decision of the european
card
and this was also done and hungary
respected the decision of the european
call mr creeper you talk about the
european commission deciding whether a
state is in line with its rule of law
values or not
look at bulgaria 14 years in the
european union it's still getting away
with some of the worst practices
of the communist era even though it's
been
under special monitoring by the eu how
does that happen
well first i don't share the opinion
that it is worse
than in the communist time
i don't i don't share it really not in
communist time
uh people suffered
under the jack on the the communist
regime under the communist area it was
uh
violating human rights every day uh we
had no democracy
no rule of law we had nothing what i
criticized in the case of
bulgaria is the system
of a rule of law concerning
to condemn the cases of corruption
we have cases which take 10
12 years in the court
it's too long it's
inacceptable uh unacceptable a
long time so there it has also something
to do with a rule of law
uh that's uh one point which i
criticized uh
very very look mr mr creek bound you
have massive government corruption
this according to independent ngos you
have mafia capture
you have democratic backsliding a
politically manipulated and almost
dysfunctional
justice system is that good so far what
how is that in any way in line
to any degree with the pledges that
bulgaria made
14 years ago and yet in 2019
a spokesman for the eu commission
reported that bulgaria had made
sufficient progress
to meet its commitments at accession to
the eu
that cannot be right can it so why this
blind eye
being turned towards bulgaria i visited
bulgaria often
and bulgaria is today integrated in the
european union
and also in the procedures of european
union that makes a difference
mr creekbound the ngos and various
gather governments seem to have
seen more problems in bulgaria than the
eu commission
the 2019 human rights report from the
u.s state department
said officials in all branches of
government in bulgaria
reportedly engaged in corrupt practices
with impunity
bribery conflict of interest elaborate
embezzlement schemes
on top of that you have from the un
committee against torture
a finding that mental institutions are
forcibly administering
intrusive and irreversible psychiatric
treatment on their
patients and that torture has become
commonplace in that country
how do those values fit in with the
modern eu
idea of what countries should be doing
of what they said they'd live up to
and haven't no that's totally right that
it is not acceptable that we
have um circumstances like the mentioned
ones but
let me say it's perhaps not a complete
picture
of bulgaria because sure things have to
be developed in the right direction
but also other points had to be achieved
in the past
and we're done um bulgaria today
cannot be compared with the times
20 30 40 years ago so all these
countries have to be developed and they
have
they are developing and so for this
purpose we have the european commission
which is observing
these developments and uh
sure that uh there is also a lot of
pressure
from the european commission to these
states but also from the other member
states
and independent uh foundations which we
have
also in bulgaria like uh conrad
foundation foundation uh but also
a lot of ngos they show another picture
but also they created they criticize a
lot of points
um especially in the fight against
corruption
their the engagement has been stronger
of the government and if the government
is not able
to to make efforts and especially
progresses then it has to
show consequences by the european union
yeah but there never are any
consequences bulgaria has had
14 years in the european union and it is
still
torturing people on a regular basis so
clearly whatever measures
the eu is applying aren't having the
desired effect are they
i think that's not the right um that's
not the right picture
because people can live free in
bulgaria and we have a democracy and all
this is
the case but what i'm asking for is a
more engaged fight against corruption
and
this cannot be tolerated because
corruption is violating
the poorest of the poorest people why
because they cannot
join this doubtful competition to pay
for uh things which should be normal
um and it starts it's not only has not
only to do with
authorities in a state but uh it starts
also in daily life in hospitals in
schools
when um when students
want to get a better uh better results
so we have um this
daily corruption let me say but on the
other
hand the high level corruption um
until it will be uh we will have a
result in
um in the fight of the state corruption
which cannot be tolerated we have to do
more in the fight against the high level
corruption and this includes that
procedures in front of the court
have to show results after a few years
but not after 10 years
that's my point so this has to be
shorter and more consequent well you're
you're remarkably complacent about it
the eu commission is remarkably
complacent about things like torture
mafia capture and uh the manip political
manipulation
of the justice system um let me turn to
another subject for the time we have
left perhaps
it's worth the eu taking a good hard
look at what's going on in
america at the moment this is the
unfolding story of a populist
president staging an insurrection to try
and prevent him
being ousted in a free and fair election
how long before some of that starts to
happen in the eu
and is the eu concerned that this in
washington should be a wake-up call
that it should listen to
well uh first uh remark uh we are really
looking forward now
um to the presidency of mr biden because
uh that's not what i asked
that's not what i asked that's necessary
to be mentioned because i
think the dialogue between the united
states and europe is indispensable
and so also the respect of rule of law
democracy is indispensable
like in america like in europe and
so i share one point that uh
in former times it was
self-understanding that
and it was common sense that democracies
are
self-understanding and are strong and
we have to observe today that
democracies
are coming more and more under pressure
worldwide
and as we had to observe it uh
now by donald trump but not only by
donald trump
so uh we have also to fight uh for our
values we have to fight for democracy
we have to fight for rule of law once
again in former times it was really
self-understanding
today it is not because this will be
decisive about the question how we will
live in 10 or in 20 years
finally mr creek brown let's come back
to germany there's a general election in
september
angela merkel is retiring and in a few
days the cdu
your party will elect a new leader while
none of the candidates
uh to date seem to be generating much
enthusiasm
your most popular politician health
minister yen span isn't even
on the ballot don't you want to win
elections
sure i'm very optimistic because we have
three candidates which are
very motivated and i'm
i don't share your your uh
introductional remark
they are very popular in in germany
and sure it will not be easy when angela
merkel will leave
um because she was now chancellor
for a very long period of time since
2005
and so that's also quite
uh normal uh that um
everybody will has its own style
uh but it's an open race and uh for me
it's very difficult to predict who will
uh who will advance one of the
candidates friedrich matz has said that
immigrants are to blame for rising
welfare costs and
unemployment in germany do you really
want your party to go down that road
putting immigrants in the firing line
just to woo a few far-right voters from
the afd
hasn't there been enough resentment and
hatred directed at
uh immigrants over the years that's not
not right when you want
to mention frederick meltz it should be
the right sentences and uh so this is
this he met he did not say but uh
what he said is now concerning the
refugees in bosnia which are at the
moment here in bosnia and out of arena
that it should not be the case that
germany
will go once again in front
because now it's also in the
responsibility of other european states
to take care on them otherwise we'll
create a pull effect uh
so which we could observe in 2015 and
2016
and this should not be repeated once
again so uh i think
um we have also areas like in syria for
example in the northern part
which are stable and so it cannot be the
solution
that um each refugee can
come to european union or in these
states
we need a solution we need a solution
um a european one because
i i think once again all these states
assign the declaration for
the geneva the geneva declaration for
to protect refugees but anyway
germany did a lot in the past and
this can be done done done one time
but not each time gunther creek bomb
unfortunately we've run out of time we
have to leave it there thanks very much
for being on conflict zone
you're welcome thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you